right here's a good place a double
staircase you see all the switch I just
it's great for like clearing land and
doing just doing work because I can just
break it like that and you see uses the
weaker of the tools think yeah I can do
a mod spotlight if you guys want me to
since uh this is an awesome mod we're
gonna need my axe boom and I don't like
that look let's make you like right like
that so here the stupid skeleton I'm
just taking my time making the staircase
because I want to be awesome because I
want to be able to go in my mom we like
have a chill staircase but you like that
yeah I know it's going to take a while
it's probably doing it also just dirt
and iron iron shovel thing I want to try
finding these skeletons and zombies you
who are you a story thirsty here
hear them blower both definitely getting
closer definitely gotten crawshaw where
are you peoples okay like right near
your above or below me oh yeah he's
right there kind of sounds a little bit
above yeah my son's above yeah there we
go see Anna switch it to the sword to
beat him down in his face haha we hit a
cave here cow this is a really high
cave-like altitude wise what's right why
we're 55 our like 10 below another this
is Cole this is not a new or but it
gives me XP so that's cool go ahead
start I'm gonna have to start killing
cows to a get bookshelves for chantaine
let's go st. chat mint then I decided
st. chanting so it kind of came out
weird just gonna bow I just got a bow I
guess I was mistaken I hear different
pigs go get all that Flint's it's good
for arrows when I do happen to be but i
left my string in my bone arrows so i'm
gonna want to regain thats how does it
actually continue on or just a pocket
yeah Micah didn't you want
oh this is the pocket okay oh there we
go there we go we got found a new or you
guys if you guys saw in the screen
probably pretty excited designing I and
this is the first time i will have mind
I knew or since I i checked the dive so
I looked at a lot of them but I haven't
like done survival and found them to
have any apples on me dang and put them
away I'll just wait to my health get my
hunger could sound a little more okay
okay awesome end is see okk go now all
of these orders you need to smelt oh one
sec guys
you
you
alright i'm back sorry about that guys
just had to handle some family matters
and if m is our mobility show alright so
we got chrysocolla or that's cool Christ
Cola or all right now can for the right
side of this mine iron so we're going to
turn that we can we in turn end yeah oh
yeah there's
you
again apologies and family matter stuff
but I'm sure you guys can chill till
that I guess more of that Chrysler
killer oh you this will talk about some
armor how are we going to make
everything into tools first up we got
some now you would think that's emerald
but it's not because we're not in a oh
my gosh why does swimming oars I love
this so much it is because I want to
find a are a cave because all of this
all right uh malachite that sounds like
an actual metal I know if but I think
all of these are because it's like
there's a grouping stuff Hank Ruby's the
best get more [ __ ] or hopefully
by the end of this whole know all these
names like my heart like I'm pretty good
with Christ Killa by now he and I just
found it no I don't want place that
place that make sure there's no more
yeah so I just I got the mob use I just
like thought it would add so much like
extra fun to the game and it I think it
is cuz oh my pic broke yes I guys
another time like wait I thought I
crashed from the pic i did I don't worry
I think if I ever find a monster spawner
then I'm going to build a staircase from
that up to my house so I can make an XP
farm this is a spider one spider 1 i'm
just going to break it did I end up
breaking the one back in my house before
I left I never visited it but if I broke
before that then I would have let's eat
some mistake steakums electra taken wish
I like pizza bites to get some pizza
bites if I record this here's like pizza
bites pizza bites and of course you're
still want Lyon since iron iron we know
is legit
and because it's kool i'll probably come
back get that later any more iron from
this just the one single iron block I
guess so hmm now let's go exploring and
I passed a ton of stuff I just want to
light this all up l'abbé how deeper we
only have 58 that a lot was freaking
high I could before I go there's so much
iron oh my gosh this is great like I
feel like this the mod made a coal and
iron spawn War two i think i just
switched my sword for a second because
that battle in front of me Scoob bat
tired do i live 18 nice
oh my gosh so much goods are you or I
have a stack and a half cool forget
insane bro I'm sorry so all of a single
pockets of iron they treat me now one
thing that's good if I ever get lost in
a cave I can just stare case out of it
so I'm never worried again lost who
anything over here is that nice cave I
kind of want to get deeper oh my gosh so
much stuff I want to get deeper so that
I can start getting some of those other
ores so there's one or that they make
tools that if you wait right click if
you right-click them they can set things
on fire and if you right-click them on
lava they get repaired so I definitely
want to get that I wasn't out door
opening to this mine it's nighttime so I
probably want to wait to leave zombie
thing just got a hacker on me I'm a
kitty for XP give me XP come in you
don't like nothing but I like that was
like nothing but i only got like one of
them should they match should aim at
prestige who I like that jump beautiful
so much longer brew never gonna run out
of iron yep Nava already had a pretty
good stack of it I got pretty good like
well stack and mean like stacked vitamin
just like chunk of it I guess some more
Christ so killa i think i was called
that I guess we'll spawns a high like
high altitudes at chrysocolla curricula
saying that wrong whatever no more
course killa frickin is commas are in
this map
due to do yes we're going deeper yes
that's what I want are some more mal
kites some a single just by itself it's
all by its lonesome guess so we'll pick
up some of this coal a pic is halfway
gold try for do except I can make a
crafting table so we can be another pic
probably do that the main reason I'm
getting poles for XP XP per position put
that there and we must go deeper should
really just be doing this at my
staircase leave my main staircase indeed
but we are exploring where the explorer
dora the explorer oh I'll get it uh I
would say I'll get it later but I wants
just gonna say I'm just gonna leave it
there I'm gonna already those two stacks
bro to shush I want to try strip mine
you just like not not even like I don't
even need to do a diamond layer even
though if I do it I'm layer I'll get
like diamonds and other stuff but uh
just like even like at this layer
because of all the drawers are here
water yup water every we're going for it
water are you
at least I like the water because it's
always a it's a constant sound which
good defined Oh kind of disappeared i'm
going sec ooh we're going to turn the
sound up guys i think this is different
oh there we go again all these oars I
think both these are new ones I don't
think is malachite yeah we have a jade
and citrine and like citrus oh we got
some oh yeah this is all of these ores
bro I'm going to need like more furnaces
because there's because so much
diversity um pics much break dang it oh
there goes these didn't didn't break on
one of the blocks I was mining no but
sucked alright so and and there we go
continue where the heck is water it
sounds like it's above me but I don't
think it is so skeleton yeah go up and
I'm really hear it apologies is a little
loud breaking the dirt and stuff what
the heck what is this are just going to
loop I hear them run around like them
jumping in the water I don't know where
it is though sounds like it's all around
me try to try going down
you get louder sounds like it's getting
louder where are you oh oh is that it oh
there we go oh there we go blow up blow
up blow up come on blow up he knew there
we go we don't want to die here I would
suck so bad are we turn the sound out of
it wonder what sound is on a hundred
percent I was really loud your skeleton
Skeletor all right